so they found cocaine at the White House
in the West Wing where the Oval Office
is Joe Biden's laughing about it and I'm
just look
they're trying to make it seem like it
might have been a tourist or something
you're not getting cocaine in the White
House past security if you're just a
tourist so of course everybody's
suggesting maybe Hunter Biden
maybe maybe I honestly think it's
probably somebody with high enough
clearance where they're not being
stopped by security but we'll talk about
this we'll get into uh uh that news
we've got some news from the past week
Rhonda Sanders when he did that when the
defense campaign posted that ad
about Trump being uh pro-lgbt or
whatever descent is actually getting a
lot of flack for this and peaky blinders
that's what's called right peaky
blinders yeah that's the show they've
they've come out and publicly denounced
to the Santa's campaign over this ad
that DeSantis campaign didn't even make
they just reposted